alright happy Friday nothing much
happening on the Internet what I missed
oh right the trailer for Star Wars up
was designed pretty big thing he's funny
because the official YouTube channel in
the YouTube video of the trailer doesn't
have the title of the movie they're just
in Star Wars Episode nine so I guess
that's what am i color here because I
guess the titles of spoiler it kind of
is but if you don't want to know the
title I'll give you this moment to step
out now now I'm gonna talk about the
title it's called the rise of Skywalker
which is a great title and it's a great
trailer but we knew it was gonna be
great trailer even if you hate the last
Jedi the constant among the core Star
Wars movies anyway because the solo
trailers never really blew my hair back
with the constant among episodes one
through eight and now nine is that the
trailers are great this is a great title
for a few reasons one it could be
talking about Luke Skywalker it could be
talking about Rey maybe her parents
weren't scumbags do you get your
possible retcon here could be talking
about kylo Ren or Ben solo because he's
technically a Skywalker though it's like
now you're also a solo but you stabbed
your dad in the chest who wants to take
that name could be talking about Hayden
we talking about anything and also it
shows fans that like no no Skywalker
it's important and remember all things
don't have to die the eternal battle
between those who make Star Wars stories
and those who make Star Wars stories
episode eight was all like with the past
time we will now call episode nine the
rise of Skywalker pointing to the past
with the poster here's kylo ren's mask
back with star here's the Emperor
laughing and cackling over the backdrop
of the busted-up Death Star radar dish
with the postern Billy Dee smash [ __ ]
run Lando run Billy Dee they're gonna
kill you don't kill him come on let the
past be the president feel like Abrams
is like yeah [ __ ] you episode eight I
had plans I mean it looks gonna be in
this you hear new dialog of him or at
least a new monologue and he's a fourth
spirit now I mean forced ghosts can come
back but I got always bring him back
right like maybe that's the rise of
Skywalker already physical Luke and
totally be in this movie to kick ass
right I mean I'm not gonna bet on it but
that'd be great and it would truly show
the rise of Skywalker also would show
that everyone knew what he was talking
about guy should become a little towel
and you could possibly imagine I don't
mean shooting lightning bolts on trees
or giving monologue to people as it goes
this kind of funny looks like we've
taught you everything we know a thousand
generations of Jedi are now in you what
about the kid with the broom flash the
kid with the broom what he sweeps what's
he gonna do we didn't teach him
everything we know [ __ ] you episode 8 I
had plans that
speaking Luke didn't teachers [ __ ] in
there it's like I've taught you
everything I know
really he taught me how to be a drunken
old grumpy [ __ ] of an uncle that no
one wants to invite to the party cool
I learned to lift those rocks by myself
by the way he certainly didn't teach her
that [ __ ] is kylo Ren power slamming one
of the Knights of Ren does their
attention among the ranks there I don't
know that's a good trailer it's a
trailer wrapped in mystery from the
title to the imagery to the dialogue it
gives you that little last like ooh
here's the Emperor cackling and laughing
though is the Emperor really gonna be in
it in reality is probably gonna be some
sort of vision that she gets about the
Emperor a warning of some sort like
who's would happen before don't be like
him he right audio we're gonna totally
put that in a trailer just to [ __ ] with
baby get them all back on our side
because holy [ __ ] the war among fandom
but that's what JJ Abrams does really
right there was like some fans are like
oh the prequels the other fans were like
oh the original trilogy [ __ ] the
prequels and Abrams was like hey the
force awakens everyone will enjoy now
it's like holy [ __ ] episode 8 happened
let the past die and Luke's oh my god he
they totally did him dirty like that
the rise of Skywalker come back people
so not only did I like this trailer just
as a trailer but the trailer was what
they needed to do title dialog and
otherwise I see the new trailer for Star
Wars Episode nine the rise of Skywalker
what did you think about this trailer
and the title whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]